bueno pues hoy vamos a pensar un poco
sobre modelos de población
acción ok y antes de empezar a hablar
sobre este tipo de modelos lo primero
que quiero hacer es presentarte a estos
dos personajes que tengo aquí and tengo
dos personajes muy importantes el
primero este es el personaje yo creo a
más nombrado por la gente cuando se
piensa en crecimiento de población y
bueno también cuando se piensa en los
límites que se pueden alcanzar en el
crecimiento poblacional este es thomas
malthus que fue un clérigo inglés además
de escritor y profesor de finales del
siglo 17 y principios del siglo 18 y
bueno entre sus ideas estaba que la
población puede crecer indefinidamente
además de que la tecnología
bueno pues ayuda a alimentar la
población y bueno también dio pie a la
idea de que el ambiente pone ciertas
restricciones sobre cuánto y en dónde
puede crecer una población y por acá
tengo a p
verhulst y bueno del cual estoy casi
seguro que estoy pronunciando
erróneamente su nombre pero él fue un
matemático belga el cual leyó el trabajo
de malthus e intentó modelar la idea de
la cual hablaba malthus es decir si no
consideramos las restricciones del
ambiente entonces la población puede
crecer de manera exponencial mientras
que si nos acercamos a los límites dados
por el ambiente entonces la población va
a crecer de una manera asintótica hacia
algún tipo de población por cierto
malthus no creía que la población
creciera de manera asintótica perfecta
él pensaba que cuando se llegaba a un
límite poblacional ocurrían cosas como
catástrofes y entonces la población
oscilaba alrededor del límite sucediendo
estas catástrofes y bueno como ves
malthus era un tipo bastante optimista
en fin pensemos un poco en las
matemáticas que hay detrás y pensemos un
poco en ecuaciones diferenciales que nos
ayudarán a entender este tipo de modelos
lo primero bueno
de pensar en una ecuación diferencial
sería bueno definir variables así que
voy a llamarle a la variable n
va a ser mi variable de población está
en el barrio presentar población así que
déjame ponerlo población y yo lo que
quiero es ver a esta n como una función
del tiempo es decir lo que vamos a
buscar es la población en un tiempo dado
n dt y esto es justo lo que queremos por
lo tanto yo creo que es lo que nos vamos
a preguntar este y en los siguientes
vídeos ahora bien para encontrar esta
función de la población yo creo que
sería muy bueno pensar en la tasa de
cambios de la población con respecto al
tiempo así que pensamos lo por aquí si
yo me fijo en la tasa de cambio de la
población con respecto al tiempo que
está pasando bueno pues esto nos habla
del crecimiento de la población y una
forma de verlo sería pensar que esta
tasa de cambio o esta velocidad de
crecimiento
es proporcional es proporcional a la
población misma y es que esto tiene
bastante sentido que sea proporcional a
la misma población por ejemplo si
tenemos una población muy pequeña
entonces la tasa de cambio de la
población con respecto al tiempo o el
crecimiento de la población con respecto
al tiempo bueno pues va a ser muy
pequeño ya que tenemos una población muy
pequeña ahora sí pensamos en una
población muy pero muy grande entonces
la tasa de crecimiento de la población
con respecto al tiempo parece una buena
idea pensar que va a ser muy grande y de
hecho esta es una ecuación diferencial
de las ecuaciones diferenciales típicas
que existen de las cuales estoy casi
seguro que tú ya has resuelto así que te
voy a encargar que pausas el vídeo justo
ahorita e intentes por ti mismo resolver
este tipo de ecuación diferencial y
encontrar la función en el dt que me dé
que me dé la solución que estamos
buscando y es que bueno de hecho es
justo lo que vamos a hacer
y te vas a dar cuenta que nuestra
respuesta es una función exponencial una
función exponencial que depende del
tiempo así que pausa el vídeo porque
justo ahorita la voy a resolver bien
pues vamos a resolverla y para
resolverlo aunque te parece sí bueno
pues dividimos todo entre n y
multiplicamos todo por d te voy a
suponer que puedo separar este dt y voy
a multiplicar todo por este dt y a
dividir todo por n y que me va a quedar
bueno si dividimos todo entre n de este
lado izquierdo me va a quedar 1 entre /
n ok y como estamos multiplicando todo
por este tema este pequeño dt entonces
éste va a pasar para acá y aquí
solamente me queda
de n esto va a ser igual ok y de este
lado derecho bueno me queda el aire
antes de ponerla con este color r que va
a multiplicar a esta en ese bar y este
desde lo voy a pasar el otro lado
multiplicando ok
dt de lujo y ahora qué te parece si
tomamos de ambos lados la anti derivada
voy a tomar de ambos lados la anti
derivada para poder obtener así la
solución de estas dos am derivadas que
tengo aquí ok y si tomo la anti derivada
de 1 entre n dn bueno pues nosotros
sabemos cuánto es eso la anti derivada
de 1 entre n de nm es lo mismo que el
logaritmo natural del valor absoluto de
n
ok y bueno suponiendo que n es mayor o
igual que 0 podemos quitar el valor
absoluto es decir si pensamos que no
tenemos poblaciones negativas pero eso
justo ahorita lo voy a apuntar mientras
que aquí me va a quedar una constante
pero ahora te la voy a escribir también
de este lado izquierdo así que del lado
izquierdo que me queda la anti derivada
de r
dt bueno pues eso es lo mismo que rte y
déjame ponerlo con este color r que
multiplica a t
ok r que multiplica t ya esto hay que
sumarle una constante una constante de
integración pero como aquí tendría otra
constante voy a reducir ambas constantes
y solamente me va a quedar una ok bueno
pero recuerda que lo que queremos es
encontrar a n como función del tiempo
así que hay que despejar a n
ahora si esto es igual a esto entonces
podemos tomarnos la función exponencial
de ambos lados o dicho de otra manera lo
podemos ver así si yo pongo aquí una en
sí he elevado a esta potencia es
exactamente lo mismo que
elevado a esta potencia es decir me
estoy tomando la función exponencial de
ambos lados entonces que me va a quedar
y ojo aquí voy a hacer algo muy
importante
voy a suponer voy a suponer que no
tenemos suponer que no tenemos
poblaciones negativas es decir que n
siempre es mayor o igual a 0 y eso tiene
toda la lógica del mundo no tiene mucho
sentido pensar en una población negativa
y bueno si suponemos que es mayor o
igual que 0 entonces aquí que nos queda
ok pues vamos a reducir un poco esto
déjame bajar un poco en la pantalla y
ahora sí si nosotros suponemos que es
mayor o igual que 0 entonces am de este
lado que me va a quedar en elevado al
logaritmo natural del valor absoluto de
n ok si en es mayor o igual que 0
entonces todo esto se reduce solamente
en n en n porque el valor absoluto de
algo mayor o igual que 0 bueno pues es
exactamente lo mismo y elevado al lugar
y natural de n
bueno el logaritmo natural y la función
exponencial se eliminan mientras que de
este lado me queda el elevado al aire
temas que por cierto esto lo podemos ver
de la siguiente manera esto lo podemos
ver ok y date cuenta de lo siguiente
esto es lo mismo que tener en elevado a
la r antes me ponerlo con este mismo
color a la r que multiplica t ok esto
multiplicado esto a su vez x am y déjame
ponerlo con este color multiplicado por
el elevado a una constante lo único que
estoy haciendo es utilizando las leyes
de los exponentes y bueno es que estoy
haciendo esto porque date cuenta de lo
siguiente si yo tengo a él que es un
número elevado a una constante esto de
aquí bueno pues es una constante así que
no nos hagamos bolas y en lugar de poner
el elevado a la cem esto como es una
constante
lo voy a sustituir por una c es decir
que he elevado a la rtp más cm esto lo
mismo que he elevado al aire
por el elevado al hacer esto por las
leyes los exponentes pero ahora sí si yo
quiero encontrar a n como función del
tiempo o que déjeme ponerlo con este
color en él como función del tiempo
quien va a ser igual bueno pues esto es
exactamente lo mismo
ok que una constante que una constante
llamada c que multiplica a en que
multiplica a la función exponencial
elevado a la rtm elevado ok a la r que
multiplica a su vez al tiempo y ya está
aquí n como función del tiempo esta es
la solución de mi ecuación diferencial
con la que empecé en esta ecuación
diferencial estamos suponiendo que la
población crece o la tasa de cambio de n
con respecto al tiempo es proporcional a
la población y entonces llegamos a esta
solución que tenemos aquí este es un
modelo de las ideas de maltos pero sin
restricciones porque si te das cuenta
esto crece de una manera
ahora si nosotros pensamos en unas
condiciones iniciales y para eso voy a
suponer que n de 0 déjame tomarlo con
este color si yo pienso en mis
condiciones iniciales es decir me estoy
fijando en la población cuando el tiempo
vale 0 si yo me fijo en la población
cuando el tiempo vale 0 es decir mi
población inicial y supongamos que esta
población inicial le pongo el nombre de
n subíndice 0 amp y lo voy a poner con
este color esto sea en el subíndice 0
entonces cómo podemos encontrar aquí el
valor de s
bueno pues n de 0 quien es am y déjame
ponerlo así si yo me fijo en n de 0 en n
ok de 0 quien es esto
si nosotros utilizamos ahora nuestra
solución esto es lo mismo que ese amplio
y déjame ponerlo así que ese que
multiplica ha elevado a la red por 0
porque en este caso el tiempo vale cero
pero r por cero es cero a cero
bueno pues eso
entonces lo que daría pues simple y
sencillamente ser y esto es exactamente
lo mismo que en ese subíndice cero por
lo que dice aquí arriba esto es lo mismo
que en el subíndice cero entonces en
lugar de ponerse voy a poner en el
subíndice cero que es una población
inicial y entonces para no complicarnos
más la vida voy a quitar estas siete
aquí
ok vamos a quitar esta sede aquí y en
lugar de poner estas en ok voy a poner
en el subíndice 0 en el subíndice 0 y
esta es la solución de mi ecuación
diferencial que tengo aquí ahora hay que
tener cuidado porque si nosotros gráfica
mos esto
bueno pues date cuenta que estamos
hablando de a una función exponencial
aquí tengo uno de mis ejes aquí tengo
otro de mis ejes ok este es el eje del
tiempo ok
mientras que este este es el eje de la
población este es el eje de n empezamos
en una población llamada en el subíndice
0 y a partir de aquí crecemos y crecemos
y crecemos y bueno de hecho la tasa de
cambios de esta función exponencial está
dada por
esta constante r pero lo que quiero
hacerte notar es que esta función
exponencial crece cada vez más rápido
rápido rápido así hasta la eternidad
pero realmente lo que habíamos comentado
es que malthus no creía eso de hecho mal
2 am no pensaba justo eso así que déjeme
poner aquí que está un poco serio porque
más de lo que creía es que existía un
límite de la población y eso es muy
importante es decir que esta función
sigue creciendo hasta un cierto límite
hasta un cierto límite que voy a poner
aquí y bueno es que este límite es muy
importante lo que quiere decir que un
modelo un poco más realista de este
crecimiento de la población se debería
más o menos y va creciendo hasta un
cierto punto después se va acercando
hasta este límite o inclusive si
queremos ver las ideas como los veía más
altos entonces la población se vaya
acercando hasta este límite la va a
pasar después va a regresar y aquí
ocurren un buen de catástrofes y todo
esto alrededor de este que es nuestro
límite pero de hecho lo que vamos a ver
en él
vídeo es que la idea de pf verhulst es
muy parecida a la idea de maltos vamos a
tener una ecuación diferencial la cual
por cierto modela mucho mejor esta idea
que tenía maltos así que no te pierdas
el siguiente vídeo